hello and welcome to this video playing
Charm City chest okay so I want to do
something else not the not the for the
rule again we can't get this line in the
Queens gambit accepted so again playing
this very quickly and confidently yeah
we'll see what happens
ok so Knight to g5 here I guess 93 this
is the most natural move but maybe maybe
have to be more coke read about the idea
of playing Bishop to e6 I wonder ok I'll
play this
there should be six looks very normal is
there anything great that I can do
against it mmm yeah I can all 94 that
was my my my idea but I'm not sure that
it leads to that much you might have
night be four years just looking at
those two squares d3 and CBS night g5 on
95 but not before it's irritating maybe
not so bad at all didn't do it so what
is the point this was my idea I just
looked good for white what what was the
idea here
you cannot move the bishop as f7 is a
big Fork yeah camera some night Jacobs
night cheeks okay now i can i can take H
sound which is very greedy move or I can
take you six for the total total bishop
pair even though he has a very reliable
looking blockade now maybe I can start
with Bishop t2 what's not when you
cannot really move a special for me six
I will skeptical about taking on age
seven while I'm not developed at all but
no maybe I'm threatening this to take on
age seven Bishop to e2 is also i am the
be four square so if i take on age seven
what is the dl f6 maybe maybe have six
okay i'm taking this so let's see how to
how to go with this like f3 I guess king
of tool will be five it's two bishops
against two nights
I came yeah this was a roof I wasn't
sure about it all ok it's not
threatening to take
yeah I think I do I want to capture not
easy at all I can still play some
strengthening moves he's not threatening
to take or to play for so I can play a
move like this but should you five
doesn't help they are Jessie I'm just
going to take
k 2 d 3 sides an important improvement i
guess and then to activate yeah okay i
go cheer for here i guess one well i
also have bishops it through all bishops
III check check check bad actually let's
check that's a good one that goes back
some are like g6 sh6 and this is already
falling falling to pieces age six is not
working yet but check check
8552 is not getting a blockade and this
is the thing I have to avoid some
blockading scenarios check so let's see
how to do b3 and Bishop tutitu maybe I'm
not quite sure about the PS placement
angling for f4 and g5 now for King a 3g
five so g5 it takes it kinjo for me not
sure about it
I'm feeling I'm feeling that I'm running
out of pawn see a little bit this could
be high morning I'd be an issue
simple ideas to take on d5 takes you
three bishops are strong they really are
I've got the wrong colored bishop but I
don't think he is able to sacrifice
sacrifice and get into the corner I
don't think he can do that check
checkmate yeah two bishops against two
nights yeah there's nothing special
going on usually this is winning and
this is this is probably one of them at
least white was a lot better I was very
surprised that he did did not do
anything against against this 95
business I was thinking first of all I
wasn't sure if this is maybe a move and
I can take take but now he's got those
ideas and I have to do something like
this I mean I don't mind that position
position much but i don't think that
black is in terrible shape here yeah
this was surprising because here i'm
just getting i think both bishops and
this cannot be that great i think it's
remarkable that stock purchase is just
giving 0.2 which is this is completely
wrong I mean sorry this is totally wrong
white is just pressing him it's probably
okay what I'm what is true i mean it's
difficult to open up the position for
white but with the two bishops against
the two nights this is not zero point
two women absolutely not I think you
helped me a lot by playing if I
after that yellow stockfish goes to 1.3
m check this is getting very difficult
check HERE winning McShane winning Jeff
or was stronger that move orders better
okay yeah I've got age 60 m and here
I've got King g3 threatening to win the
peace okay cool i watch it longer check
but the ending was also very very nice
for wide 97 here once was a better
defense why it looks pretty awkward
still it's okay it's not easy to win I
mean it's it looks very good but is it a
win that the engine wants to do this
possibly playing f5 f6 it's not clear
that I'm winning this but it's much bad
at it I think only here it's a it's a
clean win with them with the promotion
coming up okay well tough game thanks
for watching